merci alors effectivement cette
table-ronde moi je suis le représentant
officiel du secteur privé et avant d'en
venir la coproduction de sécurité juste
quelques rappels pour qu'on sache un peu
de quoi on parle
parce que moi je suis un chef
d'entreprise je suis un pragmatique et
pour moi il ya la réalité des faits
d'abord sur les effectifs sur le
territoire national il ya environ 140
mille policiers
il ya à peu près 95 mille gendarmes
ayant au moment où on parle cent
cinquante mille agents de sécurité
privés ce qui veut dire comment on parle
il ya plus d'agents de sécurité privés
dans ce pays que deux fonctionnaires de
police et a priori les chiffres je pense
qu'en termes de polices municipales on
doit être entre 25 et 30 mille personnel
sur territoire national c'est à peu près
ces ordres de grandeur
c'est vous dire que la sécurité privée
c'est pas un sujet mineur et juste pour
un rappel en dix ans entre 98 2008 le
chiffre d'affaires de ce secteur
d'activité a doublé et ça pèse
aujourd'hui à peu près 4 milliards
d'euros
c'est vous dire l'importance économique
et quantitatives deuxième chiffres pour
vous ayez un paysage à peu près clair en
tête
le nombre de sociétés de sécurité
privées je dis bien entreprises jeu mais
déjà deux côtés six mille artisans
auto-entrepreneurs j'en passe et des
meilleurs ou d'ailleurs c'est parfois un
peu le folklore mexicain
vous avez sur territoire national 3600
entreprises de sécurité
ça vous dit que c'est un secteur
extrêmement morcelé à titre de
comparaison vous avez que 200
entreprises agréées en belgique ce sont
nos proches voisins et pour un secteur
qui est chère à bruno vous avez 600
entreprises de sécurité en
seine-saint-denis est extraordinaire
c'est un département très florissant
c'est à dire deux fois plus que sur tout
le territoire de la suède
ça doit nous amener à nous interroger
sur le ménage à faire dans ce secteur
d'activité et sur ces trois mille six
cents entreprises vous n'en avez que 240
qui font plus de 100 personnes c'est
vous dire que c'est extrêmement atomisé
et là très clairement mais ça c'est un
sujet qui nous dépasse le problème ce
sera certainement le contrôle de la sous
traitance puisque le cette ribambelle de
société ne vivent pas ce que ce sont des
sous traitants sous traitant sous
traitants et c'est là que toutes les
dérives arrive
sachant que c'est un secteur qui
néanmoins concentre fortement puisque
50% du chiffre d'affaires est réalisé
par mille par les 30 premières
entreprises du secteur d'activité je
vais très rapide là aussi sur la
construction législatives nous sommes
sortis du néant par une loi de 1983 qui
est ex fondateur et 2
textes lourds ça a été une loi qui porte
le nom d'un président d'un parti
politique puisque c'est la loi sarkozy
en 2003 et qui a posé les fondements de
ce qui est aujourd'hui dans les esprits
de tout le monde
l'état comme le secteur d'ailleurs
considère qu'il ya deux maîtres mots
c'est moralisation et
professionnalisation pour faire simple
il faut des gens dignes de confiance et
il faut des gens compétents
là encore c'est juste du bon sens paysan
ce sont les deux axes d'effort et très
objectivement depuis 12 ans il ya un
gros gros travail de partenariat entre
ce secteur purement privée qui est très
atomisé qui est compliqué à appréhender
et l'état qui globalement à force de
venir tirer les sonnettes et de plaider
notre cause a fini par nous entendre
avec lequel objectivement aujourd'hui
par un certain ben d'outils comme le
cnaps avec lequel on a des échanges des
échanges constructifs avec lequel on
travaille en vrai qu'on production autre
élément de repères parce que ça fait 28
ans que j'ai créé ma modeste entreprise
qui compte aujourd'hui 1700
collaborateurs et à chaque fois que je
croise des gens dans une réunion
publique et qu'on dit qu'est ce que vous
faites si je travaille dans la sécurité
privée
invariablement dia en ce moment ça doit
bien marché donc je suis un chef
d'entreprise heureux ça fait 28 ans
qu'en ce moment ça doit bien marcher
c'est un secteur économique comme un
autre n'oubliez jamais une chose parce
que contrairement aux autres
intervenants
moi je suis soumis à une seule loi c'est
la loi du marché ma responsabilité je
suis navré c'est peut-être ça m'empêche
pas de réfléchir d'autres sujets mais ma
responsabilité s'arrête aux frontières
du contrat ma responsabilité elle est
liée aux clients aux engagements que
j'ai pris au service que je lui dois
le reste est un peu accessoire pour nous
il faut pas mélanger les missions et
c'est pour ça qu'on est parfaitement
complémentaire parce que globalement on
n'a aucune envie de sortir de nos
limites
on a une responsabilité qui est assez
assez limité ce secteur économique
contrairement à ce qu'on peut imaginer
les attentats de janvier on nous dit
assez extraordinaire pour vous en termes
de chiffre d'affaires cette affreuse qui
s'est passé mais c'est un feu de paille
ça n'a aucun sens
aujourd'hui on est frappé par la crise
économique comme tous les secteurs et
comme tout chef d'entreprise si vous
voulez mon ministère de tutelle c'est
l'intérieur celui qui me causent le plus
de soucis c'est le ministère du travail
où c'est bercy donc si vous voulez
globalement là encore et dieu sait si on
a des fonctionnaires qui sont
extrêmement créatifs et imaginatifs
c'est un secteur qui se porte mal il ya
à peine un tiers des entreprises de
sécurité privées qui sont bénéficiaires
contrairement à ce qu'on imagine on
s'imagine que c'est un eldorado
croyez bien que je rêverais que ce soit
avec un eldorado mais ça n'est pas
exactement cas d'ailleurs les marchés et
nos clients se répartissent de façon
très classique il ya 75 % des marchés
qui sont des marchés privés et 25% qui
sont des marchés publics donc l'état et
notre puissance de tutelle mais l'état
est aussi potentiellement un client est
soit dit en passant sont faire de la
provocation gratuite
il ya que ça qui est gratuit chez moi
d'ailleurs l'état est le plus mauvais
exemple en termes de donneurs d'ordres
la plupart du temps l'état donne
beaucoup de leçons mais dans la pratique
la pratique des marchés publics c'est
assez consternant parce que généralement
c'est plutôt le moins disant
peu importe après je ne critique pas le
client choisit pour la raison qu'il
veuille a pas de souci je tiens à
rappeler également que contrairement à
d'autres
l'agent de sécurité privée n'a
absolument aucune prérogative
un agent de sécurité privé intervient
comme n'importe quel citoyen vous moi
l'agent de sécurité n'a aucune
prérogative ni de près ni de loin
il n'a pas d'armement il n'a pas de
moyens il n'a quasiment rien sauf que
assez souvent c'est lui qui est en
première ligne
faites le test vous allez dans un centre
commercial ce week-end faire vos courses
et vous verrez qu'elles sont les gens
qui sont en première ligne face à la
petite délinquance ce seront des agents
de sécurité privés qui globalement des
moyens extrêmement limités alors pour
revenir sur les sujets qui nous qui nous
occupe aujourd'hui la question qui se
pose c'est la question des frontières
jusqu'où va l'état où vient le secteur
privé l'état
objectivement ça a été dit bien mieux
que moi par les intervenants précédents
l'état n'a plus les moyens de tout faire
l'état n'a plus le monopole de la
sécurité
donc ce qui est important c'est que
l'état garde le contrôle de la sécurité
il est hors de question qu'on laisse
libre champ secteur privé c'est un
représentant du privé qui parle comme ça
donc l'état et doit garder le contrôle
après je pense que l'état fait
maintenant mais contraint et forcé ce
qu'ont fait les entreprises depuis bien
longtemps c'est derrière que l'état se
recentre sur son coeur de métier
il est très clair que voir des
fonctionnaires de police ou des
gendarmes affectés à des tâches où il
n'y a aucune valeur ajoutée pour des
gens qui sont bien formés globalement
plutôt bien rémunérés ça n'a aucun sens
regardez il ya 25 ans vous auriez dit
dans cette salle écouté la prochaine
fois vous prendrez l'avion
vous serez contrôlés à l'embarquement
par des agents de sécurité privés soit
dans la salle les gens aiment rigoler
grassement soit il aux grands ils ont à
pousser des hurlements
aujourd'hui c'est notre quotidien et 2
déjà un bon moment ça ne pose aucun
problème parce que très honnêtement un
poste d'inspection filtrage quelle est
la valeur ajoutée d'un fonctionnaire de
police
des postes de ce type là ça doit rester
sous leur contrôle par contre pour le
travail au quotidien
ça doit revenir au privé ce sera un port
quality qu'un qualité prix qui sera
beaucoup plus efficace et la
problématique elle est extrêmement
simple c'est que vous avez d'un côté les
zones privées pur et dur là c'est
clairement la sécurité privée qui doit
intervenir il n'y a pas de débat sur la
zone publique
là encore pas de débat ce sont les
forces régaliennes ce sont les forces de
l'ordre c'est la police municipale qui
intervient sur l'espace public la
sécurité privée à titre personnel je ne
suis pas pressé du tout qu'elle
intervienne sur cet espace public
le problème c'est que vous avez une
multiplication de zones qui sont des
zones hybride qui sont ni totalement du
privé ni totalement du public quand vous
êtes dans un centre commercial
quand vous êtes dans une gare quand vous
êtes dans un aéroport quand vous êtes
dans un stade
est ce que vous êtes dans un espace
privé dans un espace public la frontière
est assez floue d'où l'importance de
travailler ensemble d'où l'importance de
bien délimiter qui fait quoi
parce que de vous à moi je pense que
malheureusement les moyens de l'état
n'iront pas en augmentant c'est le
contribuable qui parle mais je pense que
la tendance est assez lourde
par contre j'espère mais un comique
corrézien nous a expliqué que la reprise
est elle à plusieurs reprises donc je
suis un patron ont rassuré il n'empêche
que je pense que dès que l'économie
reviendra à meilleure fortune le secteur
privé repartir en marche avant et que
donc on remontera et qu'on passera de
150 à 200 à 250 milles parce que
clairement nous suivons l'activité
économique du pays
elle est pas florissante mais on peut
espérer des lendemains meilleurs merci
beaucoup